on n'est pas au même niveau ma société à
ce genre de choses par contre alors
c'est quoi oui attends parce que là tu
m'appelles qu'est-ce qui se passe c'est
quoi l'histoire
alors dis-moi tout
ça va être très clair là je vois que
vous souhaitez aborder un sujet dont
vous n'avez ni tenant ni aboutissant ni
explication ni réelle information donc
relayée par certains médias qui sont
simplement assoiffés de buzz et de
reconnaissance et de visibilité alors
chose que alors c'est quoi l'histoire
dis nous
deuxième chose que j'ai à dire tout ce
qui a été cité dans le générique est
totalement sorti hors contexte déformé
là moi je veux juste protéger mon image
et celle de mes enfants là c'est du hors
contexte c'est de l'invention c'est quoi
là donc il se passe rien
[Musique]
alors ça va être très simple les vidéos
qu'ils ont été tu sais j'essaye de
garder mon sang-froid je pense à un
sujet très pratique
on en avait discuté l'autre fois
voilà je suis là plus légitime à parler
de ça il y a aucune maltraitance envers
mes bébés et ça ne t'inquiète pas que le
comment dire les professionnels l'ont
bien relevé d'accord les réseaux sociaux
ont eu un énorme impact et une énorme
importance dans cette affaire donc je
m'exprimerai bonne mauvaise une très
mauvaise importance dans le tête à faire
voilà les réseaux sociaux qui ont 90%
responsables de ce qui est en train de
se passer donc pour te glisser dans le
contexte de toute façon j'allais venir
après toutes ces histoires quand tout
sera réglé et apaisé m'exprimer
m'exprimer et
lisser cette affreuse image qu'on m'a
collé comme les vidéos qu'ils ont été
diffusées par exemple sur TPMP ou
j'écrase la main de ma fille bien
évidemment on montrera pas la fin de la
vidéo ou je prends la main de ma fille
je l'embrasse pour m'excuser etc
suffit pas que on dit pas que tu attends
au rayon on montre les images pour
lesquelles les tu as les gens parlent de
ça nous on sait rien voilà
si je parle c'est c'est parce que tout
simplement c'est ce que j'avance est
fondé j'ai donc des preuves j'ai donc
des avocats j'ai donc énormément de de
points en ma en ma possession qui
permettent qui permettent excuse-moi de
d'avancer cela donc là tout ce que je
vois sur les réseaux sociaux moi je
confirme aujourd'hui et ma communauté me
croirait c'est tout ce que je veux c'est
totalement faux quand je pourrais donner
des nouvelles je le ferai là
malheureusement je ne peux pas le faire
si je peux me permettre complètement moi
je te cache pas que moi je te débarque
là je tente ton
nom de fou ce weekend donc voilà donc
l'histoire en fait l'histoire en fait
moi j'étais moi les je suis pas très
réseau je m'en fous en fait des trucs
qui se passent sur les réseaux tout ça
je m'en carre un peu le cul je vais pas
te mentir non mais tu vois mais je t’en
plus je t'aime beaucoup toi tu es venu
ici vraiment j'adore quand tu viens tu
es un amour et moi je suis très je
trouve ça très bien que tu fasses ton
business après moi
comme ça au moins tu arrêtes s'il y a
une rumeur sur toi au moins comme ça on
la coupe ce soir et comme ça c'est
terminé OK
je suis sûr
mais bon je suis
[Musique]
que pour eux uniquement pour eux dans
leur intérêt j'ai jamais fait de mal à
la maison je te crois tout à fait
j'ai jamais fait de mal et bientôt la
vérité éclatera et
tu vois quand
je sais mais nous alors nous et ce soir
et ce soir ma poupette nous on t'aime
beaucoup tu es venu ici on n'est pas des
mecs qui allons trahir tout ça donc tu
es venu ici c'est très bien passé non
mais juste c'est encore les dérives des
réseaux sociaux je sais ma chérie mais
après le truc c'est que je sais c'est
qu'après tu vois le problème c'est le
c'est les réseaux sociaux c'est un c'est
un fléau incroyable parce qu'en fait tu
tu vois c'est ce qui a fait ton succès
incroyable et derrière c'est c'est
[Musique]
j'ai jamais rien fait de mal à mes
enfants c'est la prunelle de mes yeux ça
on n'en doute pas un instant
ils ont un confort du vide ils ont tout
ils ont les vaccins à jour ils ont tout
ils ont tout l'amour ils ont ils ont
juste l'amour de leurs deux parents tout
ce qui a été contre moi a été sorti hors
contexte c'est juste c'est juste
dramatique c'est en train de se passer
c'est dramatique si je peux me permettre
on va on va on sexualiser pour noter les
spectateurs c'est qu'il y a eu des
vidéos tu montres ta vie sur les réseaux
et c'est ce qui a fait ton énorme succès
et je pense qu'il y a énormément de
jalousie aussi autour de ça voilà et
derrière les réseaux ben il y a eu
qu'est-ce qu'il y a eu Gilles parce que
des dénonciations de gens
sur les réseaux pour des soupçons de
maltraitance et d'après des infos qui
sont sortis poupette aurait été mise en
garde à vue et une enquête pénale
ouverte donc c'est parce que pour des
vidéos donc parce qu'il y a eu deux
trois signalements de gens voilà des
signalements de gens
les réseaux c'est insupportable ça va
être très clair insupportable je vais
juste te donner une précision et je
pense ça ça suffira pour pour ce soir je
suis en dans ma chambre depuis plusieurs
jours je ne vois plus les réseaux
sociaux je ne regarde pas bien raison
voilà je ne regarde plus ce qui se passe
je suis accusé de choses tellement de
rapides et c'est des choses que que
maman en tant que maman aimante en tant
que maman bienveillante envers mes
enfants je ne suis pas une maman
parfaite je suis une maman qui a fait
des erreurs pour mes enfants mais je
n'ai jamais eu de maltraitance envers
mes enfants je ne t'ai jamais eu de
négligence apparente envers mes enfants
toutes les vidéos qui ont été envoyées
contre moi etc étaient hors contexte je
pourrais expliquer vidéo une par une
contexte un par un car vous savez quand
vous savez dans ces moments-là vous avez
des combats différents là mon combat
c'est pas les réseaux sociaux j'ai un
combat beaucoup plus important d'accord
je j'en dirai pas plus j'ai un combat
beaucoup plus important actuellement
c'est voilà c'est un combat c'est le
combat de ma vie que je suis en train de
mener et je suis step by step juste ma
chérie les réseaux sociaux c'est ce qu'a
fait vraiment ton succès qui est la plus
et peut-être la plus grande star des
réseaux sociaux c'est incroyable moi je
te vois tu es tous les soirs en TT quoi
qu'il arrive tu es tous les soirs on
parle que de toi juste aujourd'hui
est-ce que toi tu te dis pas un moment
peut-être que je vais l'envie d'arrêter
ce qu'aujourd'hui tu as envie d'arrêter
ce que tu te dis pas ça y est si on peut
plus et c'est c'est ça m'a fait mon
succès mais aujourd'hui c'est c'est un
retour de bâton énorme mais moi je te le
dis je sais que c'est vraiment c'est un
fléau incroyable voilà et si oui c'est
tellement injuste en fait
mais je sais mais je le pense vraiment
moi aussi je pense que c'est un
je te dis je suis dans un combat et
quand j'aurai fini ce combat je passerai
au combat suivant le combat des réseaux
sociaux
sur moi si c'est pour ça que je t'ai
appelé tu as bien fait de m'appeler
écoute tout vraiment honnêtement ce
n'est que 10 femmes
merci beaucoup
très honnêtement je le critique personne
je ne critique pas la manière de faire
des mamans etc mais la manière dont vous
m'assimilez à certaines choses
non non c'est juste vraiment c'est parce
que en fait il y a eu deux cas ces deux
cas on essaie de 4 complètement c'est
deux cas complètement différent on le
sait tu vois voilà mais c'est quand
est-ce qu'il y a eu deux deux événements
autour de ça cette semaine même si c'est
le cas complètement différent voilà mais
mais mais mais mais mais mais ma chérie
je te dis la vérité les réseaux sociaux
je le redis c'est vraiment un fléau
c'est le fléau pour moi de ce siècle
c'est une catastrophe et je pense que
les mecs qui sont la tête des réseaux
sociaux ce sont insta que ce soit
Twitter ou que ce soit imparfait
Facebook après c'est autre chose
Facebook c'est très bien je trouve que
Facebook il y a un bon régulateur tout
ça et donc c'est un avoir mais Tik Tok
tout ça les mecs je peux vous dire ils
vont avoir des comptes à rendre bientôt
et je peux vous dire que il y a beaucoup
de gens qui vont les attaquer qui vont
les attaquer qui vont venir attaquer et
je qui vont ils vont voir beaucoup
beaucoup d'argent parce qu'à un moment
c'est pas possible ce qui se passe sur
les réseaux si un moment c'est
insupportable c'est insupportable
là tu as des accusations à tort et à
travers de tout et n'importe quoi à mon
égard je laisse je te dis j'ai plusieurs
combats qu'on prendra qui pourra voilà
je pense que toi tu devrais venir faire
du paddle avec moi tu vois ce que je
regarde les réseaux sociaux non mais
c'est vrai bon je te fais des gros
bisous et d'accord s'il te plaît c'est
mes enfants c'est ma vie entière et
c'est une communauté tout entière et je
veux pas comme ça tout simplement voilà
et toi tu es dans quel alors aujourd'hui
tu es là tu es dans quel dans quel état
d'esprit
je suis dans un état d'esprit très
serein voilà je suis très sereine car je
sais que l'injustice que ce soit sur
terre ou que ce soit de manière
spirituelle parce que je suis très
croyante ne dure jamais trop longtemps
donc voilà je suis je suis confiante je
suis sereine et j'espère que justice
sera faite et que et que voilà tout
simplement merci merci poupette je
t'embrasse merci
[Rires]
que tout le monde a mon numéro
là tu vois tu as vu quand on est
enceinte
cette jeune fille parce que moi je
l'adorais ici c'est un amour de fille et
c'est vrai que son succès c'est de
montrer sa vie moi je me demandais à un
moment je me suis dit je vais
m'intéresser parce que quand tu es venu
ici je me suis je vais regarder ce
qu'elle fait parce que je la vois tous
les soirs je vois que tout le monde
parle d'elle tous les soirs je vois
qu'elle entêté sur insta c'est pareil
c'est la folie et je me suis dit un
moment je vais voir ce qui se passe
autour d'elle et c'est vrai que en fait
son truc c'est qu'elle montre sa vie
elle emmène ses enfants à l'école elle
dit moi j'amène mes enfants à l'école
elle fait une tarte aux myrtilles moi
j'ai fait une tarte aux myrtilles voilà
et un moment c'est vrai que c'est un
succès colossal c'est monstrueux je vous
le dis c'est direct elle a fait à la fin
live je sais plus je crois qu'il y a eu
je sais plus je sais plus combien de
personnes qui ont regardé son live
c'était incroyable et c'est vrai que là
aujourd'hui moi quand je l'entends et
qui me dit les réseaux sociaux c'est
catastrophique c'est vrai que voilà en
fait c'est c'est le système qui fait
qu'elle a aujourd'hui
ma communauté ma communauté je parlerai
à ma communauté ça veut dire qu'elle est
elle-même enfermée la communauté c'est
pas la famille la communauté c'est des
followers c'est du virtuel il y a des
sœurs la communauté donc elle se
ressentent sur sa famille et c'est tout
je veux dire un moment à un moment c'est
comme Cyril quand il parle de son public
voilà c'est ça mais c'est vrai que après
je te lis et tu vois je pense que Kelly
et ceux qui sont sur les réseaux plus
ouais c'est pokédex et plus sur les
réseaux que les autres aujourd'hui en
fait c'est aussi tu gagnes énormément
d'argent elle elle est rentrée dans un
système un moment quand tu commences à
faire une vidéo tu t'es dans tiens je
vais sortir mon chien aujourd'hui tu
fais des millions de vues derrière tu as
toutes les marques qui sont sur toi bah
tu dis bah demain je vais montrer mes
enfants qui qui voilà qui font
qui joue à fortnite tu vois ou pas et
plus ça va elle a montré sa vie elle a
en vrai j'ai regardé une vidéo les
chéris c'est rien de grave je vois pas
se mentir c'est rien de grave mais c'est
juste qu'à un moment le système se
retourne contre toi et le problème que
tu as c'est que tu es en train de vie
comme je vais dire comme Benjamin
Castaldi tu quand tu dévisses tu
dévisses tu as un train de vie ta vie
c'est ça ça veut dire que tu changes
complètement de vie ça veut dire que tu
dois dire je change de vie j'arrête avec
ça je prends l'argent que que j'ai que
j'ai voilà et je repars à zéro et je
fais complètement autre chose et voilà
mais c'est vrai que aujourd'hui c'est
incroyable moi quand j'ai une ce que
elle c'est vraiment je vous dis je pense
que c'est c'est la star des réseaux je
te le dis vraiment c'est la plus grosse
star des raisons aujourd'hui quand je
l'ai en pleurs au téléphone parce que
c'est le système avec lequel elle a fait
son succès qui aujourd'hui se retourne
contre elle c'est c'est incroyable donc
qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire parce que moi
je la comprends je sais je suis à sa
place je sais pas quoi faire le problème
le problème c'est que c'est pas
tellement les réseaux sociaux mais c'est
l'image à partir du moment où on est on
se montre où il y a une image il devrait
y avoir des enfin des cellules de
protection pour ces gens-là qui vont à
la télévision et qui se rendent pas qui
sont à l'image que ce soit les réseaux
sociaux la télévision ou n'importe
quelle émission il y a aucune protection
donc il y a après comment pas besoin de
protection si tu vas à la télé tu sais à
quoi tu risques sinon tu restes chez toi
tu fais un autre travail si tu vas
protéger si tu t'exposes je pense qu'une
jeune fille tu vois ils ont un côté
enfant bon enfant on va rechercher la
famille on va vouloir partager avec elle
tout ce qu'elle vit etc mais derrière il
y a des gens qui sont pas gentil du tout
quoi on n'est pas dans un monde de
bisounours il y a des gens jaloux il y a
des gens vieux il y a des mères de
famille qui ont raté des choses et qui
sont pas forcément en bon état et qui
vont regarder là la bière d'une mignonne
comme tout qui fait voler ça crée des
jalousies ou ça crée des envieux ou ça
crée des personnes qui vont s'identifier
à elle et qui vont aller mieux
aujourd'hui voilà comment je l'entends
là comme ça au téléphone qu'est-ce
qu'elle peut faire c'est quoi la suite
elle peut pas arrêter aujourd'hui elle
est dans un système elle peut pas
arrêter c'est impossible moi je
comprends pas que ces personnes soient
pas suivies par des gens tu vois on
parle pas de professionnels mais des
gens qui savent des tuteurs sur eux je
te jure c'est utopique
donner du crédit à ce monde virtuel
parce qu'en fait dès le début elle non
mais
là
aussi le problème aussi d'accord
voilà tu es aussi tu sais que tu es mon
ami mais là tu parles d'un truc qui ne
se fera jamais aujourd'hui tu es dans ce
système donc dit d'arrêter du Redé du
crédit à ce moment de dire parce que je
veux dire c'est d'arrêter en fait c'est
un système
au bout du système mais là c'est ce rêve
bleu
je te jure et je t'adore mais qui
regarde Raymond tu crois quoi tu crois
que ça va s'arrêter parce que mais oui
quand tu gagnes des milliers d'euros
bien sûr de milliers d'euros sans rien
faire juste en amenant tes enfants à
l'école c'est-à-dire tout le monde fait
en fait
les enfants à l'école juste en faisant
ça coucou j'ai fait une tarte au mites
aux myrtilles et que tu gagnes
ça n'arrive elle n'arrêtera jamais
est-ce qu'il faut qu'elle soit il faut
qu'elle se dise maintenant même s'il y a
un drame ça s'arrêter
souvenez-vous il y a pas longtemps
non c'est ce que tu disais Guillaume tu
dis bah c'est simple en fait elle sort
des réseaux et sa vie ira mieux le
problème c'est que les réseaux elle en a
fait son monde et c'est un petit peu le
pôle de toute sa vie alors après qu'on
aime ou pas c'est sa vie à elle qu'elle
a choisi après je suis contre ce que tu
dirais moi aussi parce que tu dis oui
mais quand on est connu bah on prend
tout on prend aussi le mal et c'est
comme dans la vie réelle et ben non
parce que comme dans la vie réelle tu as
pas le mec qui va venir t'insulter en
face c'est au travail
de ma vie
je bloque une rue pour décharger mon
camion
c'est comme ça on traite d'enfoirés
à la vraie vie réellement je te le dis
quand je dis stop dans la vie c'est pas
les réseaux moi je vous le dis en face
il va jamais venir te dire ce qu'il te
dit sur les réseaux moi je vais te dire
elle a complètement raison naturel
la vidéo qui a posé problème et qui a
fait que tout le monde s'est emballé je
vais je vais vous la montrer et c'est
vrai qu'après elle c'est sa vie elle
filme tout en fait son fils qui est
tombé il a dit elle a filmé et donc
derrière voilà ça ça s'est emballé mais
c'est vrai que aujourd'hui
comme comme on disait avec Raymond
Raymond tu disais un truc il y a un
instant tu disais un truc sur les
réseaux sociaux et sur ça on va voir la
vidéo mais tu disais un truc je t'ai
trouvé que tu as tout à fait raison
parce que on gagne beaucoup d'argent en
faisant ça utiliser c'est le prix à
payer malheureusement exactement bah
c'est ça la raison parce qu'à un moment
tu peux pas avoir le beurre tu peux pas
non plus exactement c'est c'est ça le
truc si tu tu gagnes énormément d'argent
à un moment tu as tu as un retour on va
voir la vidéo ma Gégé et après je suis à
toi
depuis ce matin
de l'eau ici les pieds alors voilà donc
c'est ça la vidéo
je comprends c'est ça on lui a reproché
en gros quand elle conduit son fils à
l'hôpital il a une bosse sur la tête et
il y a des gens qui ont été jusqu'à lui
reprocher des faits de maltraitance y
compris des haters 10 ans elle aurait
elle-même poussé son fils qui est
absolument incroyable ça a été jusque-là
donc il y a une forme de exactement il y
a une forme de harcèlement contre elle
sur les réseaux on n'a pas le fond de la
faire mais c'est vrai que son état est
dû au fait qu'on l'a accusé d'avoir
blessé volontairement son fils ce qui me
paraît complètement délirant voilà
vraiment on est d'accord sur quoi
est-ce que tu avais suivi toi l'affaire
non mais non non j'ai pas suivi ça moi
j'étais avec Amandine et à mon avis
non après après c'est compliqué on entre
l'image et une fragilité il y a une
règle du jeu il y a pas il y a pas de
loi dans tous ces trucs après il y a une
espèce en ce moment en ce moment il y a
eu plusieurs affaires qui ont suscité de
vouloir accrocher les gens les punir ils
ont fait ça ils ont fait une espèce de
dénonciation massive qui a un peu
malsaine en ce moment je suis assurant
qu'il faudrait un peu remettre les
choses et pendule à l'heure et éviter
que ce soit d'office elle a une bosse et
sa mère les mauvaises mères les etc
c'est insupportable mais après non mais
moi je vais dire moi le problème que
j'ai c'est pas ton aussi alors bien sûr
ce sont les gens sur les réseaux c'est
qu'après les institutions s'en emparent
c'est ça qui est incroyable
c'est comme nous je vous dis la vérité
qui vont dire un truc et ben derrière tu
as toutes les tu as tout le monde tu as
toutes les institutions qui vont c'est
maintenant c'est n'importe quoi
maintenant ils ont vu 38 mais les mecs
faites votre vie avancez les mecs vous
avez pas autre chose à [__] non mais
sans déconner c'est ça qui rend fou je
vous dis oui comme vous je suis pas
évidemment pour les acharnements et les
achats évidemment il s'agit pas de ça
mais malgré tout son appel ce que je
vois de sa vidéo ce que ça représente le
business Kenza poupette qui est
évidemment magnifique et colossal et
c'est moi j'aime les gens qui
réussissent mais très bien pour elle et
merveilleux mais il y a un business du
voyeurisme qui me semble-t-il va être
dramatique c'est à dire que je pense que
ça va rendre des gens tarés mais
vraiment taré graves on va arriver à des
faits divers il y a Sylvie qui me dit
qu'il me dit mais mdr pardon tu vas à
l'hosto et pas tu fais une vidéo non
qu'est-ce que tu lui réponds mais oui
mais le problème c'est sa vie oui mais
est-ce que c'est la vie de ses enfants
en fait c'est à dire que je trouve que
pardonnez-moi je trouve que toutes ces
familles c'est maman ou une
responsabilité c'est-à-dire qu'elle
jette dans la lumière leurs enfants ne
mentent pas les c'est pas des objets
c'est pas des bibelots c'est pas des
codes promos donc en fait les enfants
sont jetés en peinture comme ça et après
les enfants démerdez-vous ils vont
devenir quoi ces enfants dans 10 ans
dans trois ans
sauf que dans la lumière elle fait ce
qu'elle veut mais en fait les enfants
excusez-moi non je suis désolé
Patricia ka disait entrer dans la
lumière comme un insecte fou exactement
mais moi je trouve c'est de la folie non
mais d'un côté tu as raison Géraldine
parce qu'effectivement il faut faire
attention à ses enfants qui sont exposés
qui sont mis dans la lumière etc mais en
même temps tu peux pas non plus par ton
discours donner comme une sorte de
légitimation légitimée ceux qui
viendrait harceler celle qui celle qui a
harcelé moi je trouve que effectivement
il y a un côté bon bah c'est la loi du
Far West on fait avec mais nous on est
harcelé
on a déplorer les trois mois donc il y a
plein de choses je dis pas que c'est
bien évidemment que c'est dramatique et
que c'est une société hyper violente
mais malgré tout on reste ici on est au
niveau on accepte les débats et on prend
la parole quand c'est des sujets
accidentogènes elle a raison parce que
toi la première tu en as fait les
sur les réseaux de ces insultes de ses
propos homophobes de tout ce que vous
voulez et pourtant et pourtant est-ce
qu'on fait le soir on vient bien
bienvenue à notre PMP on est content on
reste quand même donc si tu veux pas
prendre 500000 € par mois un million par
mois le système judo vous dites
si tu veux pas faire ça
système
aucune légitimation à dire ça
n'existe pas si ça existe bien sûr que
ça existe ça existe
comme moi du Maroc à 2 ans
calme-toi Daniel mot hein calme-toi oui
il y a un très beau proverbe israélien
qui dit tout ce que la vie te donne sans
effort elle te le reprend et ces gens
c'est ça c'est cette génération c'est ça
c'est-à-dire que ils sont devenus
célèbres riches ils ont tout eu ils
n'ont rien fait aucun effort pour ça
rien il se filme et il travaille pas il
y a pas d'études il y a rien et la vie
se venge toujours effectivement elle te
le reprend et là maintenant on commence
à avoir toutes les sanctions des réseaux
sociaux voilà et ça tombe et elle pleure
et je suis triste pour elle cette jeune
fille mais même quand elle pleure elle
se met encore en scène et on va dans le
sens de ce que tu dis pourquoi tout le
monde ne le fait pas à ce moment-là
c'est pas compris
tout le monde ne le fait pas à ce moment
là tu sais si simple c'est quoi la
recette je connais pas non plus mais
pourquoi
pourquoi tout le monde ne fait pas ce
qu'elle fait pour être je pense que les
enfants parce que pardon déjà je vais
être un petit peu méchant mais je pense
que sur les réseaux sociaux c'est pas
toujours les gens qui ont
ma communauté si je l'ai déjà dit c'est
des gens qui ont le talent qu'on se ces
jeunes femmes c'est mère de famille on
le talent que plein de gens se
reconnaissent en elle mais ça c'est un
talent mais si on la suit poupette et il
y a un fait du rayon pas du tout mais
pas forcément et je voudrais juste
répondre à Raymond ok quand on a une
notoriété sur les réseaux ou ailleurs on
est il y a un revers de la médaille
c'est la critique ça parfait la critique
y compris agressive mais Raymond pas les
menaces pas le harcèlement là on va
au-delà c'est-à-dire que tu fais alors
le mec tu peux pas légitimer les menaces
avec mention ça vient de me le dire
mais j'ai pas dit qu'elle était idiotes
de culture elle est pas idiote mais j'ai
pas dit l'été idiot pas du tout je dis
juste aux gens voilà dans la vie moi
j'ai vécu à la Bourse avant de j'étais
trader dans les bourses voilà et j'ai vu
qu'on était il y a eu la bulle comme ça
autour des télécoms à l'époque et tu
recous tout a explosé les gens gagnent
de l'argent très rapidement tout ce qui
se fait rapidement comme ça sans effort
cette pète à la gueule un jour même au
Rambo un jour et des bébés hein non mais
c'est vrai c'est vrai c'est vrai
il y a un départ
il y a un départ comment comment est-ce
que ces personnes commencent il y a un
départ c'est pas question
et comment elles ont commencé et après
ça devient l'engrenage non c'est un
engrenage on peut plus sortir de leur
grenade après c'est fini tu vas faire
quoi tu vas arrêter tu gagnes tu gagnes
des millions d'euros c'est je vais je
vais vous dire la le problème qu'il y a
c'est qui est en train de vie derrière
c'est que les mecs qui peuvent paraître
quand ils ont envoyé quand tu as rouler
en 4x4 Bentley tu as pas envie de
reprendre ta Clio au lendemain
contre la Suisse il se fait insulté qui
se fait insulter tous les noms
alors il a continué si tu veux continuer
tu assumes si tu veux pas continuer à
faire un baptême est dégueulasse mais
dégueulasse
Bentley mais en même temps elle veut pas
pleurer il veut pas d'ennuis bah soit tu
prends ta belle-sœur tu es les ennuis
toi tu vas dans ta période tu te fais
cracher dessus moi je connais des mecs
qui sont moi je connais j'ai un pote par
exemple qui travaille bah de l'argent
toi ouais c'est un peu quoi
tu fais rien il fait trop il fait pas
grand il vend de la chaussette en cuir
c'est bien déjà
c'est lui l'inventeur de la chaussette
en cuir Gilbert Choukroun
et ben les gens les gens l'adorent les
gens l'ador puis malheureusement dans
son délire il y a une certaine addiction
aussi à se montrer qu'elle l'a dit quand
elle a perdu son snap elle était
sans repères elle était en ouais elle
était en fait
c'est comme quand moi j'ai perdu mon
slip c'est cool je vous jure que c'est
vrai regarde-moi regarde-toi oui
regarde-moi
ça a été 15 ans à peu près de galère de
barbecue le contraire
dans les chaînes de télé les machins et
arrêter j'ai failli faire des petits peu
à la maman donné j'ai hésité
tu comprends tu les prends avant ou
après
difficulté de combat qui commence
Hanouna il a jamais connu de traverser
du désert et souvent moi j'ai traversé
avant le désert
des animateurs